welcome everyone to the panel of our
workshop in cloud intelligence airops
we'll take the next around 45 minutes to
talk about cloud intelligence in
academia as well as in industry
the topic of this panel is on how to
accelerate airoff's work in practice and
collaboration across academia and
industry
cal series plays an increasingly
important role in our daily life and the
quality of cloud platform including the
reliability availability performance
capacity efficiency security
sustainability structure has become
critical important
car intelligence airops is to infuse the
ai and machine learning into the
designing building and operation of high
quality and high efficiency cloud
at scale
today we are happy to have invited four
panelists to attend our panel before
that let me have a brief introduction of
myself
and the moderator of today's panel my
name is ching weling and a senior
principal researcher and research
manager from microsoft research asia
i'm really excited to introduce our
panelists here we have panelists for
panelists i won't go through the whole
barrel for everyone here as they are all
very senior and experienced and only by
introducing their whole buyer and
experience will take us the whole hour
they've done so much work here i want to
give a very
brief overview here
okay
going down with the alphabet order and
excited to get started
uh would you wave your hand when i
mention your name so everyone can see
you there
the first one is a professor then paid
ten pay is a ten year associate
professor at qinghai university before
joining tinhua
tempeh was a principal researcher a tnt
research in the u.s
he is an acm senior member and an ieee
senior member we know that professor
tempe has very least experience in both
the academia and industry
next we have gene cleveland gene
cleveland is a technical fellow in
microsoft and the director of
development for the core m365 host t
services
is leading the worldwide team
responsible for delivering office
productivity services to hundreds of
millions of people every hour of every
day
kevin has worked on office for more than
15 years
the server is a professor shane rule
zhangrou is a professor at university of
chicago
her research focuses on software
reliability and efficiency
shan is an acm distinguished member and
an offered piece long research fellow
her authored and course papers wrong
handful of best or distinguished paper
awards in top tier conference
our final panelist is professor tausia
taosi is a chair professor at peking
university he's an
aaa as fellow actually fellow and acm
distinguished scientist he has conducted
a series of research that has produced
high impact on the software industry
meaning several awards from microsoft
google facebook and ibm
let's welcome our panelists again
from the panelists we have very
experienced and established professors
from academia and also senior and
distinguished
technical fellows from microsoft in
industry
we expect to know the ideas from all the
panelists here about their experience
and knowledge sharing on the state of
the art research and practice what are
the top challenges and opportunities and
how can academia and industry work
together to create high impact
ok
without further ado let's get started
with the first question
what is the state of the art research
technology or practice of air offs you
would like to share or recommend and why
i want to kick this off by asking our
academic panelists
professor tempe what do you think on
that
well uh thanks touching way for the
introduction and also the question
organizing this panel um regarding the
first question i think right now uh
researchers in both academia and the
industry around the world have worked
out quite a lot of solutions for all
those individual components in this ais
domain but i know to be quick in my
opinion right now is more about you know
putting all these things together
and the build a realistic system that
can work well in practice so in my
opinion towards that goal we should
combine you know algorithm
and knowledge uh graph
and the rule-based code and the unit
human in the loop to put them together
into the same architecture and make it a
real system that would make things
really work
and towards that goal
we may need some
standards
that kind of define individual
components
so that
the industry people can
benefit from whoever is working on the
individual components and the
academia can actually work on those
individual components and contribute to
the entire ecosystem
so
in my opinion you know i you know my my
my answer to this question may be a
little bit uh too uh course green but
you know in my opinion that's you know
the whole
that the entire community should work on
and and work together towards this goal
that will really make a
uh
a big impact on their ops okay so that's
my short answer thanks to me
yes thanks a lot uh professor denpay
that that makes a lot of sense
especially about the part of the
standard uh about all those components
and the academia and industry work
together to bring the path together
so also uh what's your opinion about
that professor shangru
would you share also share your view
here
sure sure um
first of all i mean i definitely see
what dan was saying um i mean to be
honest a few years ago when this ai
thing first started i feel really
suspicious
i feel like there's a lot of topic like
i've been working on you know finding
bugs for many many years and then
suddenly see articles about oh you know
ai can write programs or ai can fix bugs
yeah i can do everything i i feel really
suspicious um but but to be honest like
um in the last few years i do see that
like this ai ops thing it is making a
lot of differences i mean in my system
community i see that um in the past i
have colleagues working on like see
resource scheduling right particularly
like in cloud right how to um
allocate resources how to you know
migrate workload all these things um
many people have worked on this for
decades and then now it is true right
that you have a lot of data you analyze
using data analytics using machine
learning you can do much better resource
scheduling
and i also see that i feel like using ai
to write a code is a little bit of
stretch
but indeed there are a lot of works and
there are also some great works from
microsoft um there was some a recent
best paper um talking about using some
uh analytics right and you can for
example predict what are the risk in
every code commit and all these things
um
and also in my own research right i
gradually kind of um lowered my my my
guard and become more and more open um
to do this machine learning thing so and
like you i there were some topics i
started working on since i was phd
building more and more complicated
analysis trying to detect bugs
and at you know one day we just decided
hey let's
give up all those complicated algorithms
um let's just uh
try with some very simple
you know kind of learning right a little
bit inference not necessarily deep
neural network all the time but just a
little bit you know study studies you
know influence and it does turns out um
to
um to you know achieve some amazing
results and we also got some best paper
by by doing things that way you know
bringing inference
um leveraging the huge amount of code
base that we have now instead of using
very complicated um you know program
analysis so i think i think
these are the amazing things but at the
same time i mean i definitely see some
of the things that um like
um professor danpe was saying right how
to build a different put different
components together and then when we put
different components together um you
will need to think about how different
things uh how the machine learning
component and now machining component
compose together
and what kind of quality guarantee right
do you get what does it how do you
explain um the results that you get and
also i've also seen that um like instead
of just saying hey
i can use machine learning for
everything right but rather say hey
let's combine right some of those domain
knowledge that people researchers have
obtained right through many decades of
research how to combine those domain
knowledge together with machine learning
so i think i think these are all very
interesting active research um that
people are doing and will continue to do
yes there's a lot of fresh genre for the
sharing yeah i can see that a lot of
people also shared a very similar view
here uh from uh
suspicious to yeah to get some belief
inside the aio and also there is a lot
of challenge ahead of us for example you
mentioned that explainability
on the results and also
how to get your lending into the real
practice
yeah
a great journey here so uh professor
tauscher would you like to also add some
comments in this question sure
thanks chimway for inviting me
to serve in this panel and together with
my distinguished
fellow panelists
um
it's good to to speak last among my my
peer academic panelists uh i think
both of them have covered uh quite well
on uh those important
uh current practices and and
even like upcoming period for
ops uh in the future research or ongoing
research i just would like to elaborate
uh on one point uh be mentioned by both
dan and shan
uh on combining human knowledge and
and ai technologies or data-driven
solutions
although nowadays
we have
many situations being monitored or
instrumented
with
footprints right the data being
collected so that we could leverage
advanced technologies
including
machine learning not necessarily deep
learning right on on such data being
collected but still
we have quite
many activities
uh not necessarily
easily or or amendable for data
collection right and like developer
activities
all like the different
data
different kind of data being collected
in different
places and and concentrating or
consolidating the data in a single place
could be a challenge right so uh i think
um having
some
kind of a form i mean
which could be
uh kind of like uh
ontologies or also
certain
domain knowledge graphs
for
human to instill either implicitly right
or explicitly the domain knowledge in
the process
recently we we had some collaboration
with ebay
on moving on that direction with a
industry system being deployed within
ebay
with our latest result published or to
be published at asc this year
by
showing
a deploy system for reflecting that
nature right using event graphs
for reflecting sun uh domain knowledge
in order to carry out some reasoning on
culturality relating the root causes and
the symptoms
i think this is a very important
direction we have seen
cases i i mean in different companies uh
for reflecting uh that direction maybe
later jim we share some uh kind of like
uh uh like the details about about uh
like some of those uh uh really advances
uh going on industry because i think
later on we will talk about the industry
academia i feel like for this field of
air of uh industry is really leading uh
with obvious advantage right with these
ops and data-driven solutions
i will stop here thank you
yes thanks professor tarzia great
sharing on the view on the data and also
the cooperation experience
with
some industry companies here
so yeah now we can see that how it was
viewed from the
academia and we learned a lot here and
next would like also to know more about
the opinion on the industry side
what's your opinion on the state of the
art research technology of practice
gene cool
well thank you first off it's always
difficult to go last in any of these
discussions because a lot of the best
topics are taken by people earlier than
me and they they talk about some of the
really major challenges that we've got
ranging from how to integrate uh
data and processes for a lot of these ai
based systems that are evolving and how
to do it across the service life cycle
because ai ops
has to cover the entire life cycle from
concept through deployment through
repeated improvement
one of the things about hosted services
is they're constantly evolving and you
really can't separate
development from deployment from
monitoring from operations like a lot of
really traditional old-school systems
did so when you say ai ops it
encompasses a huge range of of
technologies and man dan hit the nail on
the head with that one when he said
we've got to look at things like
standards for how do we enable
these systems to interoperate i i
couldn't agree with that more and then
sean had some great points there too
when she said
uh you know with ai isn't always the
best tool and deep neural nets aren't
always the best tool
uh to solve every problem
we've got to draw from a rich toolbox of
different techniques and different
capabilities
and and we've got to keep the human in
the loop and we can't throw out a lot of
what we've historically done to improve
software because this does encompass
all phases of software development that
that we're used to
and then tao talked about data my
favorite topic of all when we're talking
about ai ops because we know
ai-based systems are only as good as the
data training them and and
only as
effective and tailored as the data that
that's used to train them
uh and uh and i love that and i think he
he really hit the nail on the head with
that for one of the biggest impediments
to academia and
and commercial engagement on this
is to do ai ops you've got to have
access to the data but in a lot of cases
there's risk associated with access to
the data because things like
personal information can leak into the
data and then how do you make sure the
data is clean and it's sanitized and it
doesn't inadvertently have some of that
personal data as we're sharing it uh
with with some of our academic
collaborators to make sure that they've
got real data to work from so the
results are real and good
but at the same time we're we're
protecting the privacy of our users and
any of their data that might
inadvertently get exposed that that
access to data is uh is a one of the
most powerful parts of the engagement
but it's also one of the most risky
parts
and i think
if i would pick any single
[Music]
technology advance any single scientific
advance that would really
cause the uh
the
academic and industry collaboration to
just explode in ai ops and and become
the thing every grad student's got to
work on and everybody wants to do their
thesis on
is if we can invent technology to allow
us to do this ai ops
using private data in a way that
guarantee
preserves the privacy of that data you
know whether that's a homomorphic
encryption type approach or
uh or some type of differential privacy
where you try to get an epsilon that's
laughingly close to epsilon
uh you know i don't know what the right
technology answer is but man if we can
lick that data privacy thing uh the
world's our oyster as far as advancing
this subset of the industry goes at just
rocket fast pace
so that that's the one place i would
really love to see
some advances i'd really love to see
maybe five times as many people getting
their doctorates with uh
disciplines and domains around privacy
preserving machine learning because that
unlocks the data and by unlocking the
data
you unlock the science
that's the key
[Music]
going great sharing same stream yeah i
personally especially like your points
on that ai is not always the best tool
on solving real problems and also the
relation between ai and anti-data
and and
also the points on the provider privacy
great point here saying stream
okay now let's go to the second question
here so what's the
top challenges and opportunities in of
research and practice
anyone of our academia panelists want to
take the question first
there okay professor tempe please
uh sure um
yes so right now you know uh from what
what i can see you know in ai ops we can
improve the quality of the software and
the efficiency of you know the software
being tested and delivered and deployed
and also uh
improve the cost of you know operating
the software of course you know in these
three major domains there are different
subtopics for example
in cost management we have traffic
prediction
uh
and also resource management etc
but uh you know
based on my my own experience i focus on
the quality of the software therefore i
think the major challenges and
opportunities over there are you know
you know the the you know failure
discovery
failure prediction
failure mitigation and the root cause
analysis
these are the major
topics
that you know people are working on
around the world and
of course you know a more recent trend
is that
among all those topics you know people
are working on
instead of using individual data source
to do a failure discovery now people are
more working on multi-modal anomaly
detection
and also instead of using statistics to
do the correlation among different
signals right now
people are more converted to using some
you know uh metadata you know based on
the call graph or you know causality uh
graph you know etc so that all those
correlations actually make uh
operational sense physical significance
right and uh also on top of that you
know we do we can do all kinds of uh you
know scenario based algorithm basically
essentially you have this
recall of all the signals and then you
use metadata to do the correlation of
all these signals and then on top of
that if you think about it
failure mitigation root cause analysis
failure prediction are owing using all
those signals and the correlation so why
don't we you know do these things in a
more principled way so that all the
signals are collected different people
can work on those signal uh recall
techniques and then you know we do the
uh correlation in uh you know basing
based on metadata instead of just simple
statistics and then on top of that all
those uh algorithms are actually enabled
instead of uh each individual algorithm
you have to do your own signal uh
recall and oh your your own uh
correlation
right so you know if we can do it that
way it really you know i i really want
to echo jim's point right so basically
not just the data you know
sanitization that enable this but also
if we can give all those researchers uh
kind of a big architecture and what they
are working on is in this big
architecture and then i think all the
party around the world will
converge and and will actually work
together instead of working on
individual piecemeal and then if we are
enabled with some kind of you know
large scales sanitize the data
especially those metadata that it used
to do the correlation i think it will
enable a lot of uh things as uh jim
event you know
uh we will uh soon get a boom of this
air of the research
okay
that's how it sounds
yeah that's awesome yeah since uh for
refresher tempe yeah i see that you
mention a set of hot topics people are
working on like the detection low cost
analysis causal reasoning correlation
analysis for prediction and small
mitigation yeah great sharing here since
uh professor uh sunru would you like
also like to share your experience here
sure sure yeah so um i think that
mentioned a lot of amazing directions um
discoveries diagnosis and i think those
are exactly you know the research that
will make all my phd work like become i
i wouldn't say garbage but uh
well so so so so well so so recently
my my group so we have also looking at
kind of failure discovery should cause
diagnosis
but um not for traditional software but
for those software that
can turn the machine learning component
right so you can use machine learning to
help you to diagnose
those traditional software
but now with more and more software that
use machine learning right those new
kind of type of software itself right to
present new challenges
to failure discovery right root cause
diagnosis and just something very simple
like once you introduce a machine
learning component right and then it's
hard to tell right if if the result is
not what you want right like if you want
to say um i want to
know that oh this this photo should
include a dog but my my software that
contains machine learning component
doesn't tell me it has a dog
is it because that machine learning
model is not strong enough right or is
it because my my input right i did not
do
i did not submit my photo right using
the required resolution right or is it
because the developer right they used
they didn't read the api menu they
didn't read the um you know the say the
azure or the
google cloud
ml api manual correctly so they use the
api in the wrong way you don't know
right and then the the root cause
diagnosis becomes um it suddenly becomes
really complicated um you have to do not
just a traditional right code analysis
dependency analysis you also need to
understand right part of the machine
learning model uh and sometimes you just
don't know right whether do i judge this
as wrong right is it something wrong or
maybe it is still fine right so so
they're just whole new set of challenges
and also
we actually started like for example
looking at um those open source
applications that use machine learning
uh and you will be surprised like almost
half of the the software they're using
machine learning api in the wrong way
right they're just many developers right
um because you know part of this the one
this ai option become more popular right
the side effect is many people think
they know how to use machine learning
right
and
and then there are many developers for
example because they don't know what's
the difference between image
classification and object detection
right and and then just you and they
also don't know that um i think actually
jam then how you all mentioned right a
lot of what's the emotion then how your
machine learning component work depends
on the training data and the many
developers they don't have the sense
right what are those training data
and what kind of data right it will be
it will
suit it will be suitable um so so that's
a big
um you know big domain and i'm looking
at those software the quality of those
softwares that use machine learning it's
kind of scary right if really one day we
say hey every software will use machine
learning it will be very scary i mean
the quality would would be very bad and
in the past
um it's easy to some extent right one
human make a mistake you you can
identify oh you made a mistake because
at this line of code you had a typo
right now with a machine learning use a
deep neural network you cannot even
pinpoint right what exactly is wrong
and now just quickly see another i just
want to say
with although you know everything
machine learning machine learning
machine learning but at the same time in
order to support all these ai ops um we
need a lot of cloud resource right that
that is doing actually traditional
um data analytics right data sanitized
uh and just to to do the the the work of
doing all those you know deep neural
network computation
um so actually there there is a big
challenge um in terms of um again
reliability um even just um just going
back right for the cloud reliability
itself
there's a huge challenge there is
machine learning cannot solve all the
problems um and uh just a lot of
research is needed
yeah great sherry yeah
since
professor xianlu
especially on the points on the
relations of
machine learning and air-ops and
experience of the developers in real
practice yeah the rights and loans and a
lot of real challenges here uh ocean
points thanks a lot here
uh also uh professor uh thousand would
you like to add your comments here sure
i just would like to add
two additional points
the first point is on
collaboration among
engineers or operational engineers
together right so-called
cloud intelligence how do we enable
cloud intelligence in this setting
um
we all know like the fragrance the
mystical main month
you adding more engineers into the team
you don't get the proportionary the the
the return in terms of the outcomes
right i think even
in this uh air of uh operational
engineers
uh situation that's even more true right
because uh often
uh the the engineers would have their
uh like uh knowledge in inside their
mind right when they are doing the
debugging and and
they don't
have a convenient way to articulate
their findings right at this point even
when
one engineer couldn't solve the problem
but how could we
communicate right that that knowledge
to other people who would like to help
out right because when
uh the incident uh uh uh like under
investigation is very urgent right and
and
people would like to like uh solve them
when at the moment power but how do we
enable them right besides adding more
machine
power right using cloud to to really uh
ease the computational power side i
think that's a quite open challenge or
or like a
area that we may not see a whole lot
going on but i think it's very important
it's it's kind of like a bit
far-fetching and in terms of the
challenge ahead of us i think the first
point i would like to add is that
the collaboration among
users of the air of technologies right
to enable the cloud
uh intelligence
the second point is on trust
we all know
like the data-driven solutions cannot
give you 100 percent uh the accuracy or
results
in some
critical situations
it's very important for us to make sure
like the solutions that we have would be
really the
the right one right or the ideal one
um
often the time we may not be able to
distinguish the two cases right and
we may have a solution we we put it out
it works now
let's hope it's the right one right so
especially when you have the automation
even when you're human in the loop right
the the judgment or determination
of the
the ground truth or the the oracles
would be would be quite challenging at
times
um i think that's a a
real challenge or another challenge
ahead of us right
how do we really work with imperfect
solution which is a data-driven nature
right which means that it it can output
incorrect results
from time to time
i will share these additional two points
thank you
yeah great uh sense professor tasya yeah
i love your points on the return and the
outcomes especially uh from the
perspective of software domain
and also the points about the trust is
very critical yeah great sharing sense
let's also listen to the points from our
industry panelists jean cleveland jim
what do you think on the challenges and
the opportunities well i i kind of
cheated because i worked my challenge
into my first part of the talk with the
ppml so i'll give you what i think the
second biggest challenge is that we face
and uh and uh
you know i think ev everything
my
academic colleagues have said i totally
agree with unreservedly across the board
uh i think that uh i'm gonna add one to
what they said
which is uh which is zero shot learning
uh we process billions of documents a
day trillions of user interactions a day
uh the common problems that emerge the
the
you know four nines percentile the five
nines percentile problems uh we see
those on a daily basis and we've we've
built software to address a huge
percentage of those already
what we see now are the really long tail
of problems
uh and uh
and consequently what we need in a lot
of these cases are our models and
systems that generalize super well that
that work very well in zero shot
environments
because uh when we see problems that
occur we build remediations against that
problem ever happening again
so in in the fast fast vast majority of
problems it's something we've never seen
before it's it's something there's no
data to support to allow us to learn
from so it's really
how do we build these models so that
zero shot kicks butt
and uh and that we really
nail that
uh so that it'll be able to react to
things it's never
seen before because that that's
kind of when you're processing trillions
of things a day that's what you get to
you get to that long tail really quick
and how do we nail that long tail
that's the second biggest challenge
after privacy
yes since jim yeah zero thought learning
is a very critically important research
area yeah great point here since jim so
then now we've got the information of
the state of the art technologies the
top challenges and opportunity in your
mind
and now let's go to the third question
according to your experience in
crowd intelligence air offs what are the
difference between the academia and
industry in terms of doing research how
can we better accelerate the
collaboration between the academia and
industry and make a greater impact on
both sides
same order yeah fresher tempe would you
share your points here all right thanks
well you know i think your question have
two has two parts you know what's the
difference i write right now you know my
best
opinion is that there's not a lot of
difference because academia and industry
are working together to uh to solve ios
problems uh it's rarely
seen that you know
academia work on their own because they
don't have data right so that's that's
the easy part but on the other hand uh
how can we uh work better together to
solve real world problems you know i
mentioned earlier enough about building
a ecosystem etc and you know making all
those standards and just to add a little
bit more i think uh industry you know in
a better position in
building some infrastructure
for
the
uh
research
research around the world for example
right you know industry have the data
why don't we provide all those data uh
serving in the interface right we have
you know as i mentioned even if uh uh
the correlation need to be
need to really
take advantage of those metadata right
and
what metadata available and can be used
are based on domain knowledge who have
the domain knowledge i think industry
have more domain knowledge of course
right so why don't we actually make all
these things as a kind of platform
and so that
all the data and the you know the raw
data and the metadata right use full air
ops research are there of course we have
to have sanitization and of course we we
do have to
uh enough data quality and signal in the
data and on top of that i think that's
where academia can really contribute
right so we know what we should work on
right because you know we work together
and the industry take lead to define the
problem to work on and what are the data
needed and then on top of that we can
access the data based on you know we
have problem to work on we have the
input work on we we know what the
industry wants from uh the uh the the
algorithm as output
then you can think that you know it's
you really we work
as a whole as a community uh towards the
same goal so that's kind of um
some
uh direction then that i'm educating
in the past i try to uh for example
organize some
air ops algorithm competition
one
sad effect of that and which is also
part of my goal is to you know i work
together each year i work together with
some industry companies so that they
contribute the data and i provide the
problem and so so that you know as a
result we publish some data every year
for a specific topic
but that's too slow compared to where
what the industry what word uh require
from airops so that's why i'm advocating
this like ecosystem uh whole community
approach okay thanks
yeah says uh professor tempe yeah we
know that you have a lot of experience
in both the academia research and also
the industry research in
of starman and and yes there is a lot of
synergy here
i agree on that
professor assange would you also share
your view here
sure i mean i feel like both uh jim and
dan already said very well so i would
just maybe just share a kind of small
story from i mean my own experience
a few years ago i mean my group have
been working on you know trying to
detect
timing bugs um in distributed system and
we published a lot of papers and we're
very proud and i chatted with someone
from microsoft and his
he he just told me
i don't think it works in microsoft our
coding will be too complicated for you
to analyze i didn't believe i i told him
but i am using you know like those open
source distributed systems those are
real open source distributed system
and then my student did an internship in
microsoft and in like one week we know
that indeed our technique does not work
and of course i mean um
it's great uh you know and after that we
came up with a better solution um and
it's actually much simpler um but it
turns out as much just it works much
better in the real world
um it was a really big learn you know
lesson to me um
i i mean i know right i i knew that
industry i need to ask my industry
friend but i didn't know that there's
still a lot of things um you just have
to really need to experience um you need
to see the real code in industry and
just see
you know those like say cloud incident
what kind of incidents actually happen
right you need to see the data to
understand the research challenge and of
course this goes back to james mentioned
right there need to be some kind of
sanitization so that um there can be
better
collaboration um
you know in addition to just student
internship
um yeah so i mean for myself i'm doing
um visiting i'm visiting
microsoft now and it's just really
really helped it benefit my own research
a lot
and i really appreciate it
says professor general of sharing
his own experience in real practice yeah
also yeah welcome all the students to to
internship or visiting in microsoft yeah
i promise you that you can learn a lot
yeah
and uh
so uh also yeah jim would you like also
share some of your points here
oh sorry i forget after first uh
of you would like to take that first
okay um
i think i would like to add
a
somewhat a different angle i agree with
all have been said in terms of the
importance of
visiting microsoft right um and i myself
visited microsoft
research for for quite some time
like i mean working with chin lay on
these
ai ops
in the old days probably air ops was not
popular yet right so
working on this uh
important problem i think of course this
is very important and critical getting
hands on
real data real system
um
but at the same time i think as a
research community
we at least we should
try our best right on on the side
to
to uh expand uh channels or
ways of carrying out research for
academia i just would like to add one
example that uh
i i got involved uh um with the lead as
a
researcher
from foodang university led by professor
shimpung
basically uh um
several years ago
we we looked around uh on the open
source communities in terms of uh
uh like uh median size not to say large
size micro service systems right and we
we all know microservice systems are
commonly deployed uh in industry
um but um
in open source we don't have uh
large enough right typically at that
time we look at only like a few micro
services in a single system uh at best
like
10 i mean no more than 20 micro services
so
of course i mean this
tiny scale not to say it's a small scale
tiny scale of the microservices
would hardly reflect characteristics or
the the real challenges uh in industry
right especially i mean for for
deployment debugging
we know it's very difficult uh for
uh companies like microsoft to release i
mean your systems right light scale
systems as open source
um
but i think we can together make some
efforts at the time basically
uh professor xinpung
led a large group of graduate students
to develop uh open source uh mid-size
microsoft systems
um and
like with around i think at the time
more than 70 micro services
for for a system called chain ticket
basically simulating
uh the user experiences or buying
fast-chain tickets in china right so uh
um it's not uh
large or large enough i mean uh to to
reflect real industry practice i think
reason
careful tooling
and uh for example for fourth injection
right and
and along with some
careful workloads construction for these
open source systems
uh we still could deliver some
useful scenarios or or situations for
the academia
to work on at the time we interviewed
a dozen of companies
to
collect
real incidents and and real are from
from them uh on their own microservice
systems and then we reproduce
such or simulate such efforts and and
the the uh workloads uh for uh like
exposing the the incidents in
our
uh mid-sized
microservice benchmark systems
and and that indeed helped uh
uh crystal researchers uh to jump in
right and and because that's a the the
advantage and not just the data right
because that's
i mean when we when we work on data
the the domain knowledge i mean the the
system for producing the data would be
very important so just releasing the
data itself
it helps but uh
oftentimes it's not enough especially i
mean for people to instill the software
domain knowledge right into the uh the
process of constructing useful
technologies to solve the problem
but i agree we should acknowledge the
limitations of such
benchmark systems but
but we we should also expand our horizon
i mean on such efforts besides
putting our bets on companies like
microsoft
to allow us to to visit thank you
yeah thanks uh professor tasia so we
have only one minute left uh so uh
jim kerwin would you like to answer this
question using this uh one minute and
also you see as the closing i will uh i
will
close and i'll make one very very short
comment uh and my very short comment is
uh
industry desperately needs academia to
remain engaged on this problem because
you look at the world differently than
we do we tend to be overly pragmatic in
how we approach every problem
you don't bring that baggage you bring a
new way of looking at things and we
desperately desperately need you to work
with us on this since uh to the
wonderful panel discussion with jim
krivan sean ru tauscher and tempeh we
hear voices from both the academia and
industry and thank you for taking the
time for sharing the experience and
knowledge with all us thank you
talking to you thanks thank you thank
you
thank you bye